Your eyes help you see the world.
But you can not see this point.
Really.
If you close your left eye
and look at this cross here with your right eye
and slowly zoom in or out of your screen
the point will disappear.
This will find the exact location of your blind spot.
The cells in the back of your eye
turn the light into signals that
are sent to your brain.
But they are missing here because
here are the nerves and the blood vessels
related to the eye
And that's why you can not see everything in this area
still known as a blind spot.
If we add a line through the images and try again
you will notice that your brain complements the information
and makes you think the line is going on
instead of thinking that there is a gap in what you see.
You can also not see these 12 points at the same time for the same reason.
Try it; you will probably only see one part
of them at the same time.
The point your eye looks at is focused
but your peripheral vision is not so good, so your brain
often makes guesses about what's there.
And because there is a repeating gray line combination
your brain thinks the rest of the image is the same
and skips the black points until you look exactly at them.
These rectangles do not blink at the same time right?
What now?
They are flashing at the same time
but in fact it is not.
And if we move the other figures to them
just a few pixels, you'll see
that they do not move again.
The environment has a direct impact on how you see it
and judge things, even if the result is not accurate.
Do not you agree?
Look at these blinking squares.
What you may have missed is that
the middle square does not blink at all
And if we remove the outer square we will see that in fact
is a single color.
Now try to read the sentence in the square. (Can you read this?)
Did you see the additional word?
Your brain does not always notice mistakes like these
because it does not affect the understanding of the sentence
and your brain prefers to take a quick move rather than being completely accurate.
Try to look at the point in the middle.
When the picture does not move, the colors change rapidly,
but if it starts spinning
Changing colors either disappears or slows down.
Our eyes and brain have evolved to see
but our vision still makes assumptions based on what we have learned, remembered or what we expect.
And all these illusions / tricks take advantage of this.
In fact, it's an advantage to understand information quickly
so instead of taking every detail into account in order to be 100% accurate
which would overload the brain, he makes assumptions.
Quick judgment allows us to
we have quick reflexes and take faster, more conscious and unconscious decisions.
an integral part of human nature.
Like this halo, if you look at the center of the point long enough
the brain will make her disappear
He suggests that the information does not change and is not important
as a result, you can not see it.
Do you like luring your brain with illusions?
We've made a playlist with our favorite illusions
you can watch them by tapping the screen.
Do not forget to subscribe to more weekly, fun science videos.